35 year old josh tomlin for the second
season in a row signed a minor league
contract with the braves and it doesn't
take too long before he shows his
importance moving from the bullpen into
the rotation
ground ball left side sliding stopped by
riley who can't pull the trigger on it
and mccutcheon's aboard to start the day
you're saying okay mr harper you drive
in the first run putting up numbers
through a month this season that are
pretty close to what he did in that
monster 2015.
hits the ball the other way deep to left
sending zunya to the edge of the warning
track to catch it plenty deep to bring
home mccutchen and give the phillies the
first inning lead right-hander zach
eflin makes his fifth start of the
season
here's the o2
strike three call got him looking and
ozuna doesn't like that call but that's
a strike he can go back and look at that
one and deal with it obviously you know
everyone's got their own pre-pitch
something to get ready um you know feel
ready like you're expecting the ball
um
and then
there there's some reading of the hitter
right every hitter has their tendencies
coming into the game but then
you take into account who's on the mound
what kind of stuff they have
looked like after a slider first pitch
in that archaic has kind of jumped at
so he like he might be looking to pull a
little bit here as you saw right there
[Music]
from someone from a guy that doesn't
necessarily pull a lot
kind of tells you where his head's at so
you can maybe expect a little bit
something more
one ball two strikes effluent comes back
home
and strikes three tell him to let
somebody put a ball in place so he can
see you and talk to you while you do
something at least
[Applause]
well
he i mean if he he wants to do it on his
own we're okay with that especially if
he's doing it at the paces he's got
great stuff doesn't he
swinging to miss matt adams chases a
pitch in the dirt and eplin strikes out
the side
not a 2-2 from tomlin
a breaking ball buckles his knees and
tips him down first strike out of the
game for tomlin one away in the third
reese hoskins with that microphone on
the front of his uniform wise one to
deep center field but cuny on the move
he's still going it's gone
notice it bounced back into play it did
it's off the top of the wall
it's a double for hoskins
so runner and second one out here's
harper
hits the ball to deep center field
lacuna ranging back he makes the catch
on the edge of the track hoskins takes
third i'll tell you what acuna one of
the best center fielders in the game
best outfielders you could say uh as he
matures into his phenomenal career
one and two on ozuna effluent comes back
home and breaks off a breaking ball to
get him and finish off a one two three
four
i'll tell you what
mark is sleeping off this setting backs
up hoskins at first underhand flip to a
covering eflin tough play right there
you see the turf give away they had some
rain so he's backing up and then the
next thing you know is the back foot
gives way as he gets this chopper one
away austin reilly
finally
down on strikes here on the eighth pitch
from eflin who gets his fifth k
swing and a miss another strikeout for
zach efling another 1-2-3 inning for him
his third in a row
shoots the first pitch that he sees to
right that's a base hit
marcake is up with it holding the third
is now to put it on hoskins plate missed
a home run by what an inch is last time
off the top of the wall in center field
tomlin home of the 1-2
that ball's crushed center field
acuna watches it fly three-run home run
rhys hoskins
left no doubt that time didn't even mess
with the top of the wall well we said it
he's getting close and the closeness of
that swing
that's his first home run this year at
home hoskins three-run shot breaks it
open for the phillies as they look for
their fifth consecutive win
speaking of falling down you can hear
the rain has started to pick up his
flowers swings and misses for the first
half johann camargo flag to ride his
first time
that ball is drilled johann camargo gets
atlanta on the board with a long home
run
wow fourth of the season for camargo and
it's 4-1 camargo just absolutely clicked
the bat and the ball and it probably
felt like butter when it left the bat
[Applause]
got him swinging one away in the seventh
on the eighth strikeout of the game for
zach flynn he hit his 506th career
double the other day he's now tied all
time with a guy named babe ruth here's
the 1-1
and marquez shoots it up the gap in left
center field pretty deep going back
mccutcheon looks up it's off the base of
the fence
hazley picks it up he'll fire it in but
not before mr double
nick marchakis is in at second with his
eighth of the year
and his 507th
all time
[ __ ] puts him one ahead of babe ruth
the all-time list yeah so the ground
screw headed out there harper's saying
can i just finish my at-bat
all right so the tarp is coming out this
game obviously at this point is official
in a 4-1 game bottom of the seventh
after this 38-minute rain delay drives
his bottom here to her right center
field cooney on the move he was shaded
to left center so he had a long way to
go and he got there to make the catch
ronaldo cunha just dazzling this guy is
must watch tv makes a running leaping
grab to finish off the bottom of the
seven
[Applause]
punch down left side base it into left
and the braves get the tying run to the
plate in the ninth freeman extends his
hitting streak to 12 games of that base
hit braves down to their final out but
the tire on up there here on the knife
workman deals 2-0
yank down the line and caught by hoskins
to finish the game
a diving play by rhys hoskins and the
phillies have won their fifth straight